So where is finger retrieving all of
this information such as our user name,
our home directories, the shell?
Much of this information is found
within a file that stores information
about each user.
This file is called etc/passwd.
Let's take a look at that
file using the cat command.
Each line within this file is
an entry for a single user, and
each entry has a number of fields that
are separated by colon characters.
Let's find the entry for
our current user, vagrant.
The line looks like this,
vagrant:x:1000:1000:
:/home/vagrant:/bin/bash.
These two numbers 1000:1000 might
be different on your system, but
that's okay.
It's nothing to worry about.
The first field reads vagrant and
that's this users username.
The second field used to
store encrypted passwords.
Historically storing encrypted
passwords in this file wasn't an issue
as the hardware was too slow to
crack a well chosen password.
These days, almost every distribution
will just insert a character that is
ignored in this field.
In this case, ubuntu uses an x.
The third and fourth field store
your user ID and group ID.
We'll discuss these a bit more when we
get into talking about file permissions.
There's a fifth field here that may be
hard to see since it doesn't include
any text.
It's empty.
This field is used to store a better
description about this user.
You can see one user does have
a better description here.
Gnat's and then this full description,
gnats bug reporting system admin.
The last two fields are the user's
home directory and finally,
the user's default shell.
Our home directory is
/home/vagrant as we already knew.
And our default shell is bin/bash.